I have two older brothers
who both attended
military academies, and I think
from a very young age
I saw a military environment
and thought it was super,
super cool.
My name is Nita Qiu
and I'm a current senior in Yale
College, and I'm also a cadet
in the Air Force
ROTC program here.
Veteran's Day to me means
a day not only to thank
our service members for
what they've done,
but also it's a day
to recognize the hardships
and the sacrifices
that all service members face.
At Yale,
there have been many times
where I've needed a mentor
or I needed to ask somebody
a career question
and there's always someone who's
gone through that same struggle
or had the same question.
I realized that it's
so inspiring
to be a part of something
that's bigger than yourself.